[موسيقى]
الألعاب النارية مرتبطة
بالاحتفال لكنها تنبع في الأصل
من مكان يسوده الخوف والفولكلور
في عام 200 قبل الميلاد يعتقد بعض الناس في الصين
أن قبيلة من
رجال الجبال المخيفة Bigfoot esque تكمن في سفوح التلال
وهي الطريقة الأكثر منطقية لدرء هذا
العدو  سكاراميلا
أدركوا أن تسخين براعم الخيزران
تسبب في انفجار الجيوب الهوائية في النبات
مما تسبب في حدوث ضوضاء عالية صاخبة اعتقدوا أنها
ستبقي رجال الجبال بعيدًا
، ويُزعم أنها نجحت بعد ثمانمائة
عام في انطلق المغول الصينيون في رحلة
بحث عن الخلود وبينما هم لم يفعلوا ذلك.
لم يجد هؤلاء الكيميائيون إكسير الحياة ،
انتهى بهم الأمر إلى صنع أول دفعة من البارود في العالم ، وهو أمر
مضحك كيف أن
الرغبة في العيش إلى الأبد كانت في الأساس بمثابة
مخدر للحرب الحديثة ، ولكن على
أي حال ، بالعودة إلى القصة
، أخذوا هذا الدواء الناري الجديد كما
وصفوه بأنه محشو  في براعم الخيزران الخاصة بهم
، ولدت ألعاب كابوم النارية
إثارة لاختراع
البارود والعصي النارية في
النهاية  الطريق حول العالم
سريعًا إلى 3 يوليو 1776 ، في اليوم
السابق
للتوقيع على إعلان الاستقلال ، كتب جون آدمز خطابًا إلى
زوجته مع خطط كبيرة
للاحتفال باليوم الذي يجب أن يتم
الاحتفال به مع نيران البهاء
والاستعراض والإضاءة من هذا الوقت فصاعدًا
أراد آدامز إلى الأبد الإضاءات ،
فقد جعله يضيء السماء بالألعاب النارية
في الرابع من يوليو ، ومنذ ذلك اليوم فصاعدًا
، أصبحت الألعاب النارية
تقليدًا احتفاليًا أمريكيًا في كل مكان ، لذا
أعتقد أنه في المرة القادمة التي ترى فيها السماء
مشتعلة ، يمكنك التفكير في Bigfoot يعني
الصيني أو جون  آدامز مكالمتك
[موسيقى]
لك